hey I'm a bit and I'm Jillian and we're
both producers here at great big story
and we're here to answer some frequently
asked questions from our viewers
question one for you Jillian
yes how do you find your stories this is
the number one most asked question we
read everything the internet books
magazines listen to podcasts talk to
friends talk to so-and-so sisters
brothers aunts sister who might have a
story it sounds cliche but I think
inspiration can come from anywhere and
so you just have to stay in this
storytelling mode or story finding mode
one time I came into the office and
somebody was doing a really bad
impression of an auctioneer bid not 25
25 it's sold and I was like huh how do
you learn how to do that googled it and
it turns out there's a school break next
question how does someone get a job a
great big story great question we get a
lot I would say a good GPS producer is
somebody who's very versatile and
flexible because this job takes a lot of
very very different skills so from
finding and researching and booking
stories to working with cameras an i/o
equipment to editing it runs the gambit
all right next question what does a
regular day of production look like it
depends if you are in the field or if
you're in the office if you're in the
office you're gonna be researching
stories maybe putting together a story
that you've shot in the field the week
before and planning your next trip yep
and if you're in the field you're
probably getting up very early your
interview done and all the oil shots
because it takes I would say on average
for a two-minute great big story
probably four to six hours of raw
footage another question we get a lot is
how do we find our music what is our
music and we have a big stock library
that we choose from and we try to be
really unexpected with what we choose so
we have a story about a cowboy or a
rodeo we're not gonna use country music
we're gonna use something else to keep
it surprising for you okay okay
I really question okay I have an answer
do you have any special mementos from
being on shoots or in the field funny
you should ask that because this is my
favorite momento this is my
lava lamp it was given to me by someone
I featured I'm Frank Sanders then I am a
professional rock climbing guide I look
at it every day and I think of him and I
love it
the rock wants to be climbed and did a
lot of length have anything to do with
the story at all it had nothing to do
with the story at all
final question are there any stories
that have a special meaning to you yeah
so the story that I made about the last
lamppost
well a lamppost is the specialist who
works with lighthouse lenses is special
to me because it was inspired by my dad
he is a curator at a Maritime Museum and
he was the one that actually told me
about lamp us to begin with and
introduced me to the one that we ended
up making the video about how about you
well first of all shout out to Evans dad
thank you for the story tip my story
that has special meaning to me is
probably the story about the biker club
helping babies in need
it's just about people coming together
and I just loved these women and it made
me so happy to see them all helping each
other and doing it on Harleys thank you
so much for submitting these questions
if you have more be sure to leave them
in the comments of this video or any of
our videos yeah we'll definitely try to
answer the questions you have in these
comments and if you like this video
please let us know and maybe we'll make
another one
[Music]